hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from yesterday's chess
super league it's an event organized by
regis and chess base india and it will
last until 17th of this month and this
game is well just incredible i've
received many messages uh i've basically
just woke up and there were like 100
messages saying please analyze this game
and of course as always for good reasons
uh let's check it out and see what this
game is about so abigail gupta indian
grand master versus anishigiri uh white
opens with d4 uh anish goes for knight
to f6 we have c for e6 knights the c3
and of course uh the nimzo indian
defense bishop to b4
we have e3 going for the for the
standard stuff we always mentioned that
e3 and queen to c2 are white's most
popular replies still uh we have castles
and now usually white will go bishop to
d3 or knight f to d knight after e2 but
here we have bishop to d2 it's a a
little less known but uh in 2021
anything can be played uh we have d5 uh
striking in the center of course a
standard move in the name so indian next
we're going to go b6
knight to f3 and b6 uh we have c
characters and b5 e captures on d5 and
now rook to c1 and here you could go for
the uh thinket of the light square
bishop but anisha waits with that he
plays c5 and it's a principal decision
definitely uh as the white king is still
in the center of the board we definitely
wouldn't mind opening up the e file for
our rook so bishop to e2 white wants the
castle to safety
and now anisha advances the pawn all the
way to c4 and we always mentioned that
this is perhaps a little bit
anti-positional
uh but uh in 2021 there is no such thing
as anti-positional so rook so castles
first uh by by gupta and now a6
preparing b5 we have knight to e5 and
excellent square uh for for this white
knight and now b5 uh we have a4 white of
course wants to challenge black's
pawn structure here later on you should
definitely challenge it further with b3
uh and the queen to b6 regarding the c6
square preparing knight to c6 to get rid
of this knight from e5 we have queen to
c2 also continuing development
connecting rooks
and knight to c6 so now we're ready to
eliminate it this knight and here white
should definitely consider b3 uh we we
always have to advance uh our pawns to
attack black's
overly advanced pawn structure
especially in situations where a well
sort of an anti-positional move like c4
is played but here we don't have b3 we
have bishop to f3 and this is now a bit
of a problem
okay the
the d5 pawn is attacked twice but anish
simply defends it and this only helps
him further develop and now we do have
b3 but now it's a kind of a one move too
late because now by playing knight to e7
to guard the d5 pawn we also have
support for bishop to f5 and this is how
how anisha nicely develops the bishop
bishop to f5 attacks the queen queen to
b2 and now rook a to b8 preparing to to
open up the b file so a captures on b5 a
captures on b5 and now
white has to be very careful on how to
continue here do you just continue
maneuvering do you play b captures on c4
uh so a lot of options here but in the
game g4 was played and it seems like a
good idea as the the bishop will have to
move then you're going to dislodge the
knight and the knight is defending the
pawn and then you're going to win the
pawn uh but it has one problem so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
uh well uh the there i said the winning
move for anishier while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that it's
not actually a free piece and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
of course it's knight capture sun g4
this is what danish played and now the
point is after knight captures and
bishop captures uh we can't really win
this bishop because if bishop captures
just queen g6 we pin the bishop
the king is on g1 and if you defend it
doesn't really matter we're going to
attack with f5 and then we're going to
win it and then we just have a winning
position so instead after bishop
captures on g4 we have knight captures
and d5 now okay we've removed one of the
defenders of the d5 square
and now what do you play here well uh
it's uh it's a tricky position of course
you could just uh capture the knight for
example knight captures and d5 and if
bishop captures on d5 we're just going
to play queen to g6 and black is
completely winning here there is no
doubt about this
but as anish said in an interview after
the game he decided to play for the
crowd and he didn't go uh for the
objectively best move but he went for
the actual best move and that of course
is bishop captures on f3 so he
sacrifices his queen but then the rook
is coming to b6 and then the rook is
coming to g6 so will white be able to
survive this attack
white has nothing better if you don't do
this then just queen g6 and it's game
over uh so here knight captures on v6
the queen was captured a rook captures
on b6 and now rook f2d1 you have to make
some room for your king if you are uh if
you were to survive this attack because
rook to g6 would have been checkmate uh
so rook the g6 check still we have king
to f1 and now bishop back to d6 with the
idea of just capturing on h2 and then we
will have support for rook to g1
checkmate so bishop to a5 we have to
clear some space for our king to try and
escape and now uh knight to d5 you don't
have to rush bishop captures on h2
because we we now can move king to e1
and there is no checkmate so after
bishop to a5 we have knight to d5 and
now comes b captures in c for b captures
on c4 and again you can't capture on c4
if you capture on c4 then uh just check
and we're going to capture the rook for
example bishop captures an h2 we're
threatening checkmate and now after the
king moves rook g1 check king moves and
then we pick up the rook for free with
check and then black is completely
busted so after b captures on c4 we have
king to e1 now getting ready to get the
king up the board now comes rook to b8
activating the rook while attacking the
the white queen queen to c2 and now
comes the most beautiful move of the
game i think even nicer than the queen
sacrifice and that of course is pawn to
c3 that's uh you know such a such an
impressive move uh it takes away the d2
square from the white king and now rook
to g1 is the threat of checkmate and
there is no good way to
uh to parry this uh the only thing left
to do is to capture this pawn and free
up the d2 square for our king so this is
exactly what gupta played he played
bishop captures on c3 but now knight
captures on c3 and of course the b4
square is ready for this bishop uh you
don't have any other moves you have to
capture otherwise you're just dead lost
so queen captures on c3 was played
bishop to b4 now we win back our queen
queen captures and now of course not
queer rook captures on b4 and allow rook
to c8 checkmate again i know some of you
were thinking about this uh but instead
rook the g1 check and now after king to
d2 we pick up the rook on d1 with check
and of course we force the the white
rook to move away from the c file and
only after rook captures on d1 now we
pick up the queen now we are up a full
bishop and of course black is completely
winning so white tried uh one last
attempt maybe anish blunder's uh
checkmate
as his back rank is weak you know maybe
he made a pre-move or something you
never know it's a rapid game we we
should try everything but anish just
played rook to b to check king to d3 and
now f5 freed up the f7 square for his
king and he was in this position on move
34 that abhijit gupta resigns the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so this is a this is a great great
example of how
uh
anish of course knows both of the moves
are winning just uh
capturing the
sorry not here but after knight captures
on d5 he knows that uh just uh bishop
captures an f3 is winning the the move
that was played in the game but uh also
just capturing and the five that we
mentioned captures captures and queen to
g6 is also winning so here deciding to
to play for the crowd uh definitely is
the way uh is the way to go of course
it's an online rapid game so there's uh
um uh it's it's not like uh you know
it's
dead serious but of course it is serious
and the the deciding to go for this it's
incredible and you know uh
this is uh
uh well
just uh uh so sorry i'm uh at a loss for
four words but this is how everyone
should play chess if at all possible uh
and you know playing for the crowd is is
definitely the way to go
uh but yeah uh
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank uh rather i
wish a happy birthday to a at habib hope
you hope you had a good one and that you
will uh you know spend it with uh many
many friends at the bar in the library
and you know have many great games and i
would like to thank michael kennedy tom
carr tom daralo and francis ayer for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of uh
all the active events currently
happening in the world checking up on
your wonderful suggestions
such as this one and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day